in the West African country of Benin
where voodoo was born it is an official
religion practiced by more than four
million believers Voodoo's exact origins
are elusive but it is said to have
evolved out of the region's traditions
of ancestor worship and animism Pazza
good news is a third-generation voodoo
priest and healed
he treats patients and presides over
rituals in a shrine of the earth spirit
aza sees the benefits they are cured if
some people don't have enough money we
improve he'll do so they will get money
in mind over long in the local language
thawne voodoo means spirit while
practitioners believe in only one true
God they communicate with him through
thousands of different spirits and
shrines
even for a priest it can be dangerous to
disobey a spirits wishes years ago a
spirit demanded that Oz's daughter a
Seba become a medium a vessel for the
deity but aza wanted his daughter to get
a modern education at first he disobeyed
the spirit's commands but over time
aza realized the spirit was flirting his
plan for his daughter understand why the
teacher was saying she couldn't hear
when the teachers then she would never
find a good life for his daughter to
achieve her potential aza
has to let her become a medium this
forest harbors the earth spirit sackbut
up
here is whereas IBAs journey begins now
our daughter wants to worship God the
rest up to you suddenly the spirit
claims a Sivas body overcoming these
people believe the Spirit has actually
killed a senior now in the grip of
spirits of the dead the girl's body
received gentle care given with the hope
that in time the Earth Spirit will
return to life a SIBO will lie here for
three days without food or water
aza hopes to see a Seba reborn but he
knows her fate is up to the spirit three
days later the spirits of the Dead still
control a Sivas body
her father aza
hopes they are about to give his
daughter back me today the course of a
new medium is still in Sion now we want
to open the door
Ellenberger from here in front of the
community a spray of cornmeal rids the
path of evil to signal passage from the
world of the Dead to the world of the
Spirit
the body must come feet first into the
village open palms invoked the spirit
inviting it to return in voodoo contact
with the chicken purifies the body
preparing it for birth still a Seba
seems lifeless a priestess calls on the
spirits to release their hold on her
body
finally a muted cry
this display of spirit power overwhelms
worshippers a series of ceremonies
purifies a Simba's physical self with
his daughter revived and rewarming aza
feels enormous relief now that my
daughter is resurrected I can relax the
world of the Dead tradition a Seba still
need years of training but in time she
will take her place as a spirit